If there's one thing
I've learned,
whether it's high school
or the real world,
it's that the only way
to get respect
is to take it.
I'm smelling a gender war.
Bring it on.
Remember, the key is
getting power first.
Then when you're on top,
you can make change happen.
Maybe we should do something
a little more than protest.
What do you want me
to do?
♪♪
Wait 'til you see
what I got.
What?!
The administration has
been watching us.
What do you think, Farrah?
It's indefensible.
Do you realize
what we have here?
We have confidential
information
on half of the school.
I think that's
the superintendent.
Oh, my God.
So, do we have
a scandal?
-Who else knows about this?
-Nobody.
Yet.
♪♪
This stays between us.
Eveyone has their secrets.
Don't! You cannot post
those photos.
This is a huge story.
Yeah, but it's not
your story.
We need to take
this kid out.
Three, two, one.
Your move, girlfriend.
So, I guess
homecoming's toast.
Not like you had a date
anyway.
♪♪
Thanks so much
for watching the new trailer
for my show
"Youth & Consequences."
Be one of the first
to binge the whole series
on March 7.
Click right here to sign up
for YouTube Red.
You can try it for free
for 30 days.